I'm gonna be driving around with Jordan
it's really cool I think wait 1960s 500
is the smallest car I've ever been in
pink
thousand your name
and the fal'cie no winery and I believe
they also have property that contains
truffles which are a fungus that grows
underground I believe we're gonna go on
the hunt for some wild truffles hey
we're at one of Jordans favorite
wineries fell Cena I was gonna say that
rings castle nuovo baronet Dana it's a
great winery enter in times with the
person I like the least it's a hot line
the alcohol tastes higher in relation to
the structure in the body tell us what
else forest is enough I may not feel
like I'm lost in the literary know you
here is that right yeah you've been
bragging about how you're a big deal in
this restaurant I mean the owners know
me some of the way there's no me I can't
you say you
I can't attest to the fact that every
dishwasher knows me
[Music]
okay Graz ie and the next where is amici
am i seei
it's exciting over the town of Cortona
where George is going to be given a high
honor this is the band history group
they're officiating and then we're gonna
be arrested probably in half an hour
that's go leave on Los Angeles hello
[Music]
got an auto grill on the Italian
autostrada in this case it's a uno a one
this is some of the best sandwiches and
coffee in all of Italy there's a luxury
highway rest
that's bracel them you know that's
people that's not important
Russell is a current beef
[Music]
you